wir schauen auf einen wahren
freizeitpark horror das ganze passiert
in rheinland pfalz das ist jetzt
sommerferien das wetter wo man in diese
freizeitparks geht mit der familie aber
dann passiert dort an dieser achterbahn
dass seine frau aus dem saarland die
fliegt plötzlich bei voller fahrt raus
aus dieser achterbahn das was wirklich
ein albtraum absoluter albtraum mehr die
57-jährige die fliegt aus ihrem sitz
stürzt meter tief zu boden und stirbt
ein zeuge erhebt jetzt schwere vorwürfe
sie suchte den nervenkitzel und fand den
tod es ist der albtraum für jeden
freizeitpark besucher bei voller fahrt
fliegt eine frau in rheinland pfalz aus
der achterbahn der horror unfall
passiert im wild- und freizeitpark
klotten in rheinland-pfalz direkt an der
idyllischen mosel eine der größten
attraktionen des parks die heiße fahrt
eine 5 132 meter lange achterbahn mit
einer höhe von 17,5 metern am samstag
ist die 57 jährige aus st wendel im
saarland mit ihrer familie zu besuch im
park sie steigt in die achterbahn freut
sich auf die aufregende fahrt auf
rasante kurven und rausch der
geschwindigkeit und dann das plötzlich
fliegt die frau aus ihrem sitz stürzt
mehrere meter tief und prallt auf den
boden einsatzkräfte eilen zum wild und
freizeitpark an der mosel doch für die
57 jährige kommt jede hilfe zu spät die
frau stirbt an ihren schweren
verletzungen
der horror-unfall in rheinland pfalz vom
wochenende kein einzelfall immer wieder
kommt es in freizeitparks zu tragischen
unfällen einige enden tödlich
erst mitte juli stirbt bei einem
schweren unfall in einer achterbahn im
dänischen aarhus ein 14-jähriges mädchen
im september 2021 stürzt eine 6 hier aus
einer achterbahn in einem freizeitpark
im us bundesstaat colorado und kommt ums
leben wie konnte der schreckliche unfall
in rheinland pfalz am wochenende
passieren war es ein technischer defekt
oder grober fahrlässigkeit
das ist jetzt gegenstand von
ermittlungen ein fahrgast der am samstag
vor ort war sagt gegenüber bild dass vor
der fahrt offenbar die sicherheitsbügel
nicht ausreichend kontrolliert wurden
kurvenreich maximales gefälle und bis zu
60 stundenkilometer schnell so werben
die betreiber die achterbahn auf ihrer
internetseite die fahrt nichts für
angsthasen teilte die achterbahn mit dem
namen die heiße phase wurde zur
tödlichen falle die suche nach
nervenkitzel für die frau aus sankt
wendel endete die töten
ja und jetzt suchen die ermittler den
ganzen tag nach der ursache für dieses
schreckliche unglück unser bild reporter
jonathan under ist dort bei den
ermittlern und gerade schon gehört die
sicherheitsbügel die sollen eine ganz
entscheidende rolle gespielt haben wenn
man denkt ja immer da kann eigentlich
nichts passiert das wird dauert
überprüft hier möglicherweise nicht
jonathan
ja das ist gerade gegenstand der
ermittlungen es wird in alle richtungen
ermittelt ob ja da möglicherweise die
sicherheitsbügel nicht ausreichend
kontrolliert wird wurden laut einem
zeugen mit dem wir am samstag gesprochen
hatten der auch dort war ihm kurz bevor
dieses unglück passiert war mit seiner
tochter
da dieser achterbahn gefahren ist der
sagte die sicherheitsbügel seien nicht
richtig kontrolliert worden sagte auch
was besonders
schlimm ist dass diese frau da
rausgeflogen sei und erst mal gesucht
werden musste also da das so ein
unbestreitbares schwieriges gebiet das
ist hügelig da ist überall wald
also die die rettungskräfte mussten
erstmal die frau suchen und haben sie
dann von noch versucht wiederzubeleben
also der blanke achterbahn horror
spielte sich hier hinter mir ab
mittlerweile hat sich auch der
parkbetreiber auf seiner website zu wort
gemeldet und hat sein tiefes bedauern
ausgedrückt hat gesagt die gesamte
belegschaft ist schockiert
und fassungslos
und ja alles weitere wird wird sich
jetzt über den über den tag
herausstellen der park auf jeden fall
ist ja geschlossen und bleibt
geschlossen bis auf weiteres ist nämlich
an
ja gestern war die ansage dass gestern
geschlossen werden sollte aufgrund
betrieb einem schwerwiegenden
betrieblichen grund heute wird man da
schon konkreter und spricht von einem
tödlichen unfall auch heute ist der park
geschlossen und auch heute werden hier
die ermittler den genauen gründen
nachgehen das wird sich erst mal niemand
tun da hat ein achterbahn park ohne
benutzbare achterbahn danke jonathan
under unser bild reporter dort nach
diesem schrecklichen achterbahn unfall
[Musik]